is it okay to kill in self-defense or
say if you are in the army
what if you if you are working on the
army no no no no
we are uh what's the expression um
conscientious objectives we're
non-combatants 70 atmospheres we go as
medics we go in any role that does not
require taking a life
because
even if you weren't a christian do you
really understand why you're fighting
do you really and
government can tell you whatever it
wants do you really understand why
you're about to kill another 18 year old
who himself does not understand why he's
shooting at you but as a christian no no
taking of life
adventists are non-combat that goes all
the way back to the 1860s we're
non-combatants
we don't kill people we don't kill
people
we have a god who can defend us not even
in self-defense
you can defend without killing
god is not sleep god can defend remember
when 50 men came to get elijah and god
sent fire consumed them
ahab sent 50 more god sent fire consumed
them the next 50 that came said please
come with us they were very nice they
said please come and i just said okay
god defends his people and he is he
taught us that in several ways when the
israelites are not israelites well i can
refer to them but gideon when gideon was
called by god to deliver israel from the
midianites gideon raised an army of 33
000 men god said no no no no too many
because if you win you did it so it will
look reduced that number he reduces to
ten thousand too many he reduced thirty
three thousand to three hundred
and they never raised the sword he sort
of got a pitcher a lantern and a trumpet
the armies killed themselves
never raises there never is the sword
eloise said it was never god's will that
the israelites should conquer by warfare
but by plain and simple obedience and
when god destroyed the egyptian army in
the red sea he was demonstrating i will
take care of your enemies
you
obey me
when the devil came to tempt job
and when again god said hast thou
considered my servant job a perfect and
an upright man one that feareth god and
his truth evil then satan answered the
lord and said does job fair god for not
hath not thou made a hedge about him and
about his house and about all that he
hath on every side
a hedge of protection because job was
obedient we don't kill we don't maim
we trust god
and god has mighty angels who can
intervene on our behalf
you